let's head on over to a fatal auto  pedestrian crash now this happened just  about an hour and a half ago it is shut  down westbound trop  at paradise here's a snapshot of what it  looked like a little bit ago and we have  our own live picture there with  photographer chad graves on scene so  here we are with a lot of police on  scene an auto pedestrian crash no  details on exactly what happened except  for the complete closure of westbound  tropicana at paradise you can still turn  left to go south into mccarran but if  you're looking to go all the way across  top towards the strip you're going to  have to go down or up to flamingo  because westbound trough is closed at  paradise john heather